on commence par l'article 1er avec une
demande de prise de parole de madame
laurence rossignol
moi aussi je me réjouis que des avancées
qui vont être faites aujourd'hui au
sénat tout en déplorant la méthode
les nombres d'heures les atermoiements
les résistances qui se sont manifestés
depuis deux ans a posé un interdit clair
pour toute relation sexuelle entre un
majeur et un mineur de moins de 15 ans
ceci étant dit dans cet article 1er ray
amende et réécrit à l'international je
ne reviendrai pas ce serait peut-être
grossier sur le fait qu' un certain
nombre d'amendements adoptés
internationale était exactement ce
qu'ils avaient été rejetés ici c'est
probablement le travail parlementaire sa
joie et sa qualité qui aboutit à ce que
les choses évoluent entre les deux
chambres
pour autant dans les amendements qui ont
été apportées l'amendement dit clause
roméo et juliette ne paraît pas
acceptable si ce n'est à considérer
qu'il faut toujours quand même un petit
peu protégé les auteurs
il ya une certaine cohérence entre ce
qu'ils ne voulaient pas d'un seuil de 15
ans et ceux qui veulent aujourd'hui d'un
amendement va d'une clause fixant un
écart de cinq ans entre l'âge de la
victime et l'âge de l'auteur
vous dites vous parler d'amour à deux
descentes
est ce que vous savez que l'âge moyen de
la première relation sexuelle et de 17
ans et 6 mois pour les filles et de 17
ans pour les garçons
ce qui revient à dire que vous vous
entendre vous apprêtez à protéger des
relations sexuelles entre un garçon ou
une sur un gars le plus souvent un
garçon de 19 ans et un garçon ou une
fille de 14 ans 3 ans et demi avant
l'âge moyen
et puis enfin les amours adolescentes
pour tout vous dire quand j'entends ces
mots je pense que c'est exactement aux
violences sexuelles sont mineurs ce
qu'était le crime passionnel ou
féminicide une seconde demande de prise
de parole sur l'article un monsieur
arnaud de bellonnet merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président même la
rapporteure chers collègues mon
intervention à a deux objectifs le le
premier que soient bien évoquer les
personnes handicapées mineurs et majeurs
dans nos débats comme cela était lors de
nos précédents débats je voudrais
simplement rappeler la réalité de ce
fléau à travers deux illustrations une
étude de la direction de la recherche
des études de l'évaluation et des
statistiques de juillet 2020 qui
démontre que la probabilité de subir des
violences sexuelles est multiplié par
deux pour les vieux pour les personnes
handicapées et une autre étude des
travaux de recherche présentée au
congrès de l'encéphale en 2019 à paris
par le docteur ben gourion et madame
séverine leduc qui là aussi a fait la
démonstration que 88 % des femmes
autistes signalé une ou plusieurs
violences sexuelles seulement sexuelle
ce qui veut dire qu'une petite fille qui
n'est autiste a une chance sur dix de ne
pas subir de violence sexuelle enfin
même pas des autres formes de violence
seconde chose que que je voulais
exprimer ici c'est qu'eric un certain
nombre de nos collègues nous avons
réfléchi et travaillé au dépôt
d'amendements concernant les personnes
des enfants handicapés en particulier et
personnes handicapées
de manière générale sur ce texte et
notamment avec philippe pouillé qui a vu
cette démarche en première lecture qui
avait porté cette démarche en première
lecture ne les avons pas déposée nous
avons convenu d'une simple prise de
parole parce que
réalité légistique et qu'il n'y a pas
d'amélioration légales et notamment
d'amélioration possibles dans le code
pénal pour protéger davantage les
personnes handicapées et les mineurs en
particulier les sanctions sont déjà plus
forte que pour d'autres victimes
et dès lors cela nous oblige monsieur le
garde des sceaux à une nouvelle
interprète nouvelles interpellations
comme ont été interpellés les précédents
ministres sur ses bancs lors de débats
de cette nature et cette interpellation
a les seins dès lors que la loi ne peut
améliorer le dispositif
on en appelle à la mobilisation du
gouvernement pour améliorer et
enclencher une dynamique réelle sur les
mesures de prévention de formation de ce
fléau qui touche les personnes
handicapées nous avançons aujourd'hui
pour les mineurs pour tous les mineurs
c'est heureux le fléau réel cible
particulièrement les personnes
handicapées aussi merci monsieur le
garde des sceaux de redire et j'espère
que vous impulsera une plus grande
dynamique que vos collègues qui se sont
précédemment exprimé de redire parce que
vous partagez votre préoccupation sur le
sujet que je viens d'évoquer pardon de
ce déplacement monsieur le président
merci merci chers collègues donc
l'amendement nous allons entamer la
discussion d'un amendement l'amendement
numéro quatre tombes puisque le l'unique
signataires de cette année nous on n'est
pas présent et ensuite nous abordons la
discussion de quatre amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
commençant par l'amendement numéro 10 12
c'est madame de la gontrie ou madame de
la gontrie
merci monsieur le président il y a un
problème de rédaction dans le texte qui
fait que en choisissant le terme commis
nous ne pouvons pas couvrir tous les cas
de figure selon que la victime est
majeur au mineur et que l'auteur est
majeur au mineur et donc nous avons
proposé son remplacement par le terme
exercer de manière à ce qu'il soit clair
que les deux situations sont possibles
et qu'il s'agissait il s'agit bien de
protéger le mineur ou bien merci
amendement numéro 2 présenté par madame
benbassa
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement avant tout pour but de
clarifier la rédaction du texte
en effet la rédaction actuelle de
l'alinéa 19 de l'article 1er
qualifiant le viol le viol incestueux à
cela lorsque le majeur est un ascendant
ou toute personne mentionnée à l'article
222-8 2-3 ayant sur le mineur une
autorité de droit ou de fait exclus de
la liste des auteurs les fleurs et ceux
qui n'ont pas sur la victime une
autorité de droit ou de fait et qui
peuvent être mineure au moment des faits
cet amendement vise ainsi à corriger
cette erreur rédactionnelle en
instituant que les viols ainsi fier sont
commis par les personnes mentionnées à
l'article 222-3 du code pénal sans
condition d' autorité de droit ou de
fait que à mon numéro 7 min merci
monsieur président en ajoutant la
mention ayant sur le mineur une autorité
de droit ou de fait la proposition de
loi amoindri son ambition et diminue la
protection des mineurs victimes
d'inceste car une autorité de droit ou
de fait devra être démontrée alors même
que les auteurs de faits criminels ce
sont des membres de la famille cette
faille favorisera l'impunité des
agresseurs or il est essentiel qu'il n'y
ait pas de confusion et de rappeler que
l'inceste est un interdit
anthropologique
merci madame meunier enfin l'amendement
numéro 3 madame benbassa je sais pas
saisie merci monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues comme pour mon précédent
amendement
cet amendement a pour but de corriger
une erreur rédactionnelle à l'alinéa 2
is not de l'article 1er à l'endroit
cette fois ci de sa définition de
l'agression sexuelle incestueuse
donc j'ai déjà oui c'est le même
oui l'année dernière vous aviez la bnda
ça vous aviez 12 amendement l'amendement
numéro de l amendement numéro 3 je ne
suis pas sûr vous ayez pas déjà présenté
la rédaction actuelle lorsque le majeur
et l ascendant ou toute autre personne
mentionnée à l'article 222-23 ayant sur
le mineur une autorité de droit ou de
fait est que c'est encore une fois de la
liste des auteurs les celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas sur la victime une autorité de
droit ou de fait et qui peuvent être
mineure au moment des faits les
agressions à cessieu sont commises par
les personnes mentionnées à l'article
222-23 sans avoir à y inclure des
conditions supplémentaires je veux le
même amendement
bien sûr ces quatre abonnements à vis de
la commission
merci monsieur le président donc mes
chers collègues le premier amendement
c'est remplacer le verbe commettre par
le verbe exercice donc cet amendement
propose une modification sémantique pour
préciser que dans l'hypothèse où un
mineur subi une fellation imposé par
l'agresseur le mineur ne commet pas la
pénétration mais l'exercent
je me suis bien sûr mais aussi interrogé
sur l'emploi de ce terme à la suite
d'une audition
mecheri vais la conclusion après avoir
examiné la manière dont elle est rédigée
le code pénal qu'il est employé dans ce
cadre de façon parfaitement neutre il
renvoie simplement au fait d'accomplir
un acte mais sans connotation de
culpabilité en l'occurrence le texte ne
prévoit pas que le mineur commis un viol
il indique seulement ce qui est
factuellement exact le mineur pénètre le
corps de la taille de l'agresseur si
celui-ci lui impose une fellation
mais cela ne fait évidemment pas du
minho
violeur car il faut un élément moral
pour caractériser la frasque
l'infraction et cet élément est
évidemment absent donc l'ajout d'un
nouveau terme dans le code
alors que le verbe commettre est employé
par tout risque d'entraîner plus
d'interrogations que de clarification
nous avons effectivement chercher
perpétré accomplir on en a cherché
plusieurs mais ceux qui liront le code
pénal n'auront pas forcément
connaissance de nos débats aujourd'hui
ils se demanderont quel nuance
législateur a bien voulu introduire en
désignant en distinguant l'acte de
pénétration commis par le majeur de
celui été exercée par le mineur donc ces
considérations nous ont conduit à
émettre un avis défavorable sur
l'amendement ou concernant de notre
collègue ben bassat sur le crime de viol
incestueux constitué constitue en cas
d'actes de pénétrations sexuelles commis
par un membre de la chaîne donc ils
avaient été repoussés par la commission
mardi donc il propose d'élargir mes
considérablement la définition du viol
incestueux en prévoyant que tout acte
sexuel commis par l'une des personnes
dont on a la liste à l'article 222 23 du
code pénal donc je ne voulais redit pas
le crime pourrait être caractérisé sans
que l'on ait besoin d'établir un élément
de contrainte menace violence aux
surprises sans que soit exigé un rapport
d'autorité et quel que soit l'âge des
deux partenaires donc cet élargissement
posera un problème constitutionnel
puisque il aboutirait à criminaliser
automatiquement un rapport consenti
entre par exemple le neveu et la tente
même s'ils sont tous les deux majeurs
cela pose un problème au regard du
principe de liberté sexuelle qui découle
du principe de liberté individuelle
donc on se demande également dans
l'hypothèse où deux adultes qui ont à
peu près le même âge aurait des rapports
sexuels sans contrainte sans rapports
d'autorité qui serait le coupable qui
serait la victime
donc vous vous prenez l'exemple d'un
frère et d'une soeur qui auraient des
rapports sexuels si on ne s'interroge
pas sur le consentement des deux
partenaires
si on ne recherche même pas l'existence
d'un rapport d'autorité dont l'un des
partenaires auraient abusé qui devra
figurer dans le box des accusés
les deux partenaires devront ils être
poursuivi devant les assises
vous voyez donc au delà des problèmes de
principe qu'il soulève le dispositif
proposé par est tout simplement une
hausse opérationnelle
l'amendement numéro 7 donc c'est la
suppression de la condition d'autorité
de re2 fait pour constituer le viol
incestueux ou l'agression sexuelle à
sextus donc il propose de supprimer
l'exigence d'une relation d'autorité de
droit ou de fait pour caractériser les
infractions de viol ah c'est sûr ou
d'agressions sexuelles à cessieu donc
d'une certaine manière j'ai expliqué
dans tout à l'heure par anticipation
dans mon discours de discussion générale
donc je comprends la volonté de certains
de nos collègues dans le mieux disant
pour la protection des mineurs mais
notre responsabilité c'est quand même
d'adopter des dispositions législatives
qui soit applicable en toute
circonstance et qui permettent surtout
de dédier sans ambiguïté le coupable est
la victime donc si jamais cet amendement
était adoptée en cas de relations
sexuelles incestueuses c'est
automatiquement le partenaire majeur qui
serait considéré comme l'auteur d'un
crime ou d'un délit et comme là on parle
d'un crime de viol puni de vingt ans de
réclusion criminelle
il me semble que nous devons bien
réfléchir à la question donc j'insiste
sur ce point parce que vraiment ça je l'
ai vu dans ma commune une dans une
fratrie un fils de 17 ans surtout s'il
est l'aîné de tous les frères par
exemple il peut avoir l'ascendant sur sa
soeur de 18 ans et demi et s'il impose
un rapport sexuel à sa soeur de 18 ans
et demi c'est lui qui devra être
condamné et non sa soeur au prétexte
qu'elle a plus de 18 ans donc si elle va
au commissariat en fait c'est elle qui
est de 2 victime elle va sortir coupable
donc on voit bien que cette solution que
vous nous proposez n'est pas
opérationnel donc chers collègues mais
qu'elle pourrait même aboutir à des
erreurs dramatiques donc dans ces
affaires il est vraiment indispensable
des années au cas par cas qui a imposé
le rapport sexuel à l'autre en abusant
de l'autorité de droit ou de fait qu'il
exerce sur les membres de la famille par
exemple
c'est possible bien sûr
beaucoup de psychologues le diront qu'il
est fréquent dans les relations
incestueuses entre collatéraux qu'une
personne et l'ascendant sur l'autre
bien évidemment et les parents les
premières apparences peuvent parfois
être trompeuses et ça l'a encore faut
pas l'oublier examen très précis des
faits peut permettre à la justice de
prendre une bonne décision
donc l'avis de la commission et n'est
donc pas du tout favorable à cet
amendement et l'amendement numéro 3 donc
c'était l'élargissement de la définition
de l'agression sexuelle incestueuse donc
il poursuit le même objectif que
l'amendement numéro 2 des mêmes moteurs
que nous venons d'examiner il concerne
cette fois le délit d'agression sexuelle
à ses soutes de précédents c'était sur
le sur le viol donc il est indispensable
que la justice étudie au cas par cas les
protagonistes dans cette situation donc
c'est aussi un avis défavorable bien
donc avis défavorable de la commission
sur ces quatre amendements monsieur le
ministre à vis du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président sur
président de la commission des lois
madame la reporter madame de la halle
ont pris d'abord je répondre à
l'amendement que vous ou déposés et
rappelé que commettre un fait n'est pas
commettre un crime
[Musique]
d'ailleurs pour compléter si si je puis
me permettre ce qu'a dit madame la
rapporteure l'article 222-23 du code
pénal utilise le verbe commettre sans
aucune confusion possible
on distingue évidemment bien le mineur
qui est victime de l'auteur l'auteur
commet un crime et là en l'occurrence la
victime peut commettre un fait je suis
donc défavorable à votre amendement
s'agissant des autres amendements je
suis défavorable il s'agit de celui de
madame le pen bassin il s'agit de une
madame la sénatrice de la montre il
s'agit de l'autre amendement de la même
masse à pau pour les mêmes raisons et je
dois dire que les explications qui vous
sont apportés par madame la rapporteure
sont lumineuses mais à proprement parler
lumineuse et je trouve pas d'autres mots
l'exemple que vous donnez sur le frère
et sur la soeur c'est lumineux ça vaut
plus que n'importe quelle explication
était inaccessible
on est au coeur d'une réalité que
d'ailleurs vous avez connu dans votre
pratique professionnelle et que vous
nous expliquer parfaitement
deuxièmement il ya un impératif
constitutionnel enfin il n'échappe à
personne qu'on ne peut pas créer de
crime automatique et donc il est tout à
fait important évidemment que cette
notion soit intégrée dans notre loi à
venir
je suis donc dit favorable à tous les
amendements qui ont été présentés bien
donc les quatre amendements avec deux
avis défavorables et donc la dame de la
gontrie
explications de vote et on va aller on
va les soumettre au votre un parent donc
sur le premier donc puisque les
explications je vais soumettre les
amendements au vote un parent donc donc
sur l'amendement numéro 12 vous voulez
on expliquer son vote sur l'amendement
numéro 12 pas d'explications de vote
sont annoncés apprêtez à faire une
explication globale donc sur
l'amendement numéro 12
je le soumets on voit avec un double
avis défavorable qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté
ensuite amendement numéro deux demandes
d'explications de vote qui est favorable
cet abonnement qui est content qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté un
amendement numéro 7
donc madame de la gontrie
amendement de mes recettes et si vous le
permettez président l'amendement trois
quarts c'est le même concept sur lequel
je voudrais revenir quelques instants et
et l'aspect lumineux de la démonstration
de la rapporteure n'est pas arrivée
jusqu'à moi sans doute parce que je suis
plus éloignés dans l'hémicycle il s'agit
ici d'une notion très importante
simplement pour que les collègues aient
bien conscience de l'importance de ce
que nous allons voter
nous allons accepter que le concept d'
autorité de droit ou de fait soit pris
en compte par rapport à la qualification
de l'infraction d'inceste je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure je crois en commission je
ne sais plus si je les dis dans la
discussion générale
l'un c'est ce n'est pas un crime de
pouvoir c'est un interdit et donc
considérer qu'il faut rechercher
l'exercice d'un pouvoir pour le
qualifier est un contresens total
la deuxième chose que je voudrais
rappeler c'est que vous préciser c'est
que il ne faut pas considérer le code
pénal comme un distributeur automatique
c'est à dire que bien évidemment sur la
base de faits d'une enquête
on constate qui est l'auteur qui est la
victime quelles sont les circonstances
de l'espèce
etc etc et c'est seulement ensuite que
l'on peut identifier
si les motifs constitutifs de
l'infraction pour lequel la personne ni
poursuivis sont réunis donc je dis ça
pour rassurer la rapporteure donc on ne
peut pas prétendre que on aurait une
soeur un frère poursuivis indûment etc
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe c'est
à dire qu'il ya une enquête et que c'est
à ce moment là que l'on distingue qui
comment les choses se sont passées et si
la victime est effectivement une victime
ou pas et si l'auteur est effectivement
un coupable possible ou pas donc j
insiste j'insiste en disant que sans
vouloir faire trop de prémonition si le
sénat et finalement le parlement décide
est
de retenir cette notion tout comme
d'ailleurs celle de l'écart d'âge sur
lequel nous reviendrons tout à l'heure
eh bien je suis prête à prendre les
paris que dans quelques mois nous serons
saisie d'un texte qui devra revenir sur
ces notions funeste qui auront
considérablement amoindri l'objectif que
nous avions poursuivi
et enfin monsieur le garde des sceaux le
critère de la constitutionalité sans
vouloir être cruel à l'excès c'est celui
que vous nous avez opposé pour refuser
le seuil d'âge de 15 ans une autre autre
explication de vote
madame aude signoles je voudrais revenir
sur l'amendement dans même d'un compte
rien de parler qui est celui qui
consiste à retirer
l'exigence que l'auteur de ces actes
sexuels incestueux sur la victime soit 2
doivent être une personne exerçant une
autorité de droit ou de fait deux qui
part non nous dans ce 3e en nous parlant
des conjoints et concubins d'une
personne font jouant concubin de la mère
faisons simple voile conjoint ou
concubin de la mère
ce qui revient à dire que lorsqu un
conjoint ou concubin de la mère aura une
relation sexuelle avec une mineure ou un
mineur il faudra en plus prouver qu'ils
exerçaient bien une rolex sur une
relation d'autorité de droit ou de fait
sur l'enfant moi je crois que depuis
quelques depuis deux ans nous essayons
de rendre le droit simple simple pour
les victimes
simple pour les interdits qu'il pose
dans la société est simple pour les
praticiens du droit que sont les
magistrats
nous cherchons à éviter les critères
supplémentaires qui rendent plus
difficile la qualification et en
l'espèce demandé au juge d'aller
identifier si le concubin et dont le
conjoint était bien dans un exercice
d'autorité sur l'enfant est-ce qu'il
s'en occupait
est ce qui lui donnait des consignes est
ce qu'il disait son carnet est ce qu'il
s'occupait du carnet de liaison et
qu'une fois qu'on aura dit que le
conjoint concubin en fait ne faisait
rien d'autre dans cette maison que
d'être le conjoint de la mère et qu'il
n'avait qu'il ne s'occupait pas des
enfants
on en déduira que donc il n'ya pas
violent mais il n'ya pas crime de
relations sexuelles sur enfants vous
rendez bien compte que là on ne facilite
le travail de personne dans cette
affaire là et on est pas l'interdît or
nous savons que en matière de violences
sexuelles se pose sur enfants il y a un
vrai sujet avec les conjoint ou concubin
des maires s'est identifiée mais cela on
leur crée une petite niche pour leur
permettre d'expliquer que comme ils font
rien à la maison on n'atteint même pas
les poursuivre monsieur monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président je
souhaiterais rectifier ce que vous avez
dit que vous allez madame la sénatrice
de la gontrie n'ai jamais été opposé aux
seuils de 15 ans contrairement à ce que
vous dites ailleurs vous n'avez pas dit
que dans l'hémicycle vous êtes répandus
un peu partout en disant cela je vais
vous rappeler je vais vous rappeler ce
que très précisément je vais vous
rappeler madame très précisément ce que
j'ai dis parce que j'ai pris les débats
voyez-vous tels qu'ils ont été consignés
qui sont incontestables comme ça ça vous
évitera et maintenant et à l'avenir de
répondre ces fausses nouvelles
voilà ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit madame le
seuil de 15 ans comporte un risque
constitutionnel ce que je redis ce que
je ris laissez-moi terminé dit pas mais
voilà laissez moi finir s'il vous plaît
souffrez que je termine mon propos voilà
moi aussi madame vous êtes toujours
aussi désagréable mais voyez-vous le
venin le venin le venin me tient pas
forcément lieu de talent sachez le une
fois pour toutes
je voudrais donc terminer mon propos oui
ben la matière voyez on pourra
je aller où je voudrais terminer elle je
voudrais terminer mon propos est
fustigée ici publiquement votre mensonge
madame la sénatrice le seuil de 15 ans
avait jeudi comporte un risque
constitutionnel ce que je redis si nous
sommes dans l'automaticité du crime
et s'il n'y a pas de proportionnalité et
j'ai ajouté voyez vous madame je tiens
ce document votre disposition ce n'est
pas une question tranchée elle est
délicate mérite une réflexion un
approfondissement de nos travaux j'ai
travaillé je suis revenu et je dis ce
que j'ai à dire sur cette question bien
donc nous nous avons eu les changes
d'explications de vote
nous allons passer donc au vote avec un
double avis défavorable sur l'amendement
numéro 7 qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient n'est pas adoptée sur
l'amendement numéro trois mêmes votes
même vote bien nous passons l'amendement
numéro 5 présenté par madame de la
gontrie ou madame rossignol madame
rossignol
nous avons eu l'occasion déjà de dire
que cette ce critère d'écart d'âge qui
conduit à ce que en fait la loi que nous
sommes en train d'élaborer de voter ne
s'applique pas lorsque le mineur a 14
ans et le majeur 19 ans ne nous paraît
pas poser un interdit clair sur les
relations sexuelles entre majeurs et
mineurs
ces histoires d'amours adolescentes sont
de la littérature
je l'aï dit tout à l'heure je ne leur
dirai pas dans les mêmes termes
elles ne sont qu'une façon de chercher
encore à amodiés la portée de la loi
et quant à l'inconstitutionnalité mais
depuis trois ans on nous explique que ce
que nous proposons est
inconstitutionnelle et puis depuis trois
ans nous voyons le parlement avancé à
tout petits pas et ce rallye en fin de
compte aux propositions que nous faisons
parce que nos propositions sont les plus
protectrices et que en instillant un
seuil un écart d'âge
en fait vous en revenez purement et
simplement au seuil de 13 ans qui était
celui que vous vouliez dès lors qu'il
s'agit d'un jeune majeur qui est mise en
cause
donc nous pensons aujourd'hui que notre
amendement vise à clarifier la portée de
la loi clarifier l'interdît et clarifier
la matière judy légistique est donné au
juge pour agir
enfin monsieur le garde des sceaux
permettez moi de vous dire que que vous
ne soyez pas d'accord avec ma collègue
marie terre de la gontrie me paraît une
chose qui s'est avérée dans ce débat
mais comme il nous arrive souvent nous
parlementaires ne pas être d'accord avec
des ministres et les ministres pas
d'accord avec nous ça ne vous autorise
pas à être discourtois comme vous l'êtes
avec l as discourtois comme vous l'êtes
avec elle madame de la gontrie n'est pas
l'avocate des parties civiles dans cette
affaire nous ne sommes pas dans une cour
d'assises nous saurions parlement
vis de la commission sur cet amendement
merci monsieur le président mais j'ai
mes chers collègues donc là il s'agit de
supprimer l'écart d'âge de 5 ans pour un
crime de viol sur mineure de 15 ans et
pour le délit d'agression sexuelle sur
mineur de 15 ans donc je vais reprendre
un peu les choses que comme l'indiqué
dans mon exposé cette différence d'âge
de 5 ans est l'un des éléments qui
garantit la constitutionnalité du
dispositif afin de ne pas criminaliser
des relations consenties qui peuvent
exister mais vraiment qui peuvent
exister entre un mineur d'un petit peu
moins de 15 ans et un jeune majeur
supposons qu'on supprime cet écart d'âge
de 5 ans prenez un mineur de 14 ans qui
peut avoir une relation tout à fait
légale avec un mineur de 17 ans et demi
et bien cette relation deviendrait
automatiquement criminelle au moment où
le plus âgé des deux partenaires donc a
atteint l'âge de 18 ans cette
situation-là serait difficilement
défendable au regard du principe
constitutionnel de nécessité des délits
et des peines et ça c'est un cas
pratique
là encore qui peut exister vraiment on
va pas envoyer aux assises
un jeune de 18 ans et un jour donc bien
sûr ya le principe d'opportunité des
poursuites qui pourraient éviter que le
jeune majeur soit traîné devant les
assises
cependant il est quand même difficile
pour un parquet de classer sans suite
des faits s'ils sont constitués que le
législateur aurait décidé de qualifier
de crime
nous devons donc être cohérent avec
nous-mêmes nous ne pouvons pas qualifié
certains comportements de crime
c'est-à-dire la fraction la plus grave
puis expliqué dans la minute qui suit
que certains des comportements visés ne
pose en réalité pas de problème et
doivent pas être poursuivis
il nous appartient de définir des règles
qui soient générale et impersonnelle et
qui pourront s'appliquer à toutes les
situations visées sur un plan que je
qualifierais le plus politique je
signale également que le seuil de 15 ans
assortis de l'écart d'âge de 5 ans
permet en réalité d'atteindre l'objectif
que nous poursuivions au sénat en
adoptant un seuil de 13 ans puisque nous
avions augmenté la protection détresse
car nous devons être cohérents avec la
position que nous avons
adoptée c'est une position réaliste qui
tenait compte de l'existence de ré lassé
de relations consenties entre des
mineurs d'un peu moins de 15 ans et de
tout jeunes là woerth parce que ça c'est
la réalité de la vie tchô bien merci
donc avis défavorable de la commission
ali du gouvernement le ministre merci
monsieur le merci monsieur le président
on devrait tous se réjouir des avancées
que porte ce texte un seuil
enfin un seuil l'inceste la prescription
plus protectrice des victimes
la pénalisation de cheveux qui paie de
jeunes prostituées mineures de 15 ans
las extorsion voilà cinq avancées qui
sont majeurs et on me dit mais on a
attendu beaucoup de temps on tergiverse
vous n'êtes d'accord avec eux rien mais
que n'avez vous madame la sénatrice ce
rossignol quand vous étiez ministre en
charge de la famille pris un texte
réglant cette question une fois pour
toutes
vous n'avez pas pris l'ombre de lance
d'un texte en la matière je me permet
quand même de vous le rappeler parce que
voyez-vous la critique est facile et
l'art est beaucoup plus difficile alors
pour le reste bahia la vie qui
s'imposent à nous nous avons des enfants
nous savons qu'ils ont une vie sexuelle
quand ils sont adolescents eh oui si les
chiffres nous disent que la première
relation sexuelle d'une jeune femme dans
notre pays ces dix sept ans et quelques
mois il ya des relations sexuelles qui
sont consentis pour des jeunes femmes
plus jeunes
il ya des amours adolescentes ne vous en
déplaise et souffrait de l'entendre ça
c'est pas de la statistique
c'est l'avis voyez la vie toute simple
et moi je ne veux pas ne vous en
déplaise à encore être le grand censeur
des amours adolescentes
je ne veux pas que grâce ou à cause de
cette loi on renvoie devant la cour
d'assises un jeune majeur tout jeune
majeur qui a eu préalablement à sa
majorité une relation sexuelle consentie
avec une gamine
la question qui se pose non mais quand
on veut être l' arbitre des élégances
comme vous on laisse au moins les
interlocuteurs s'exprimer voyez-vous
complètement
vous m'avez donné des leçons vous adorez
faire cela depuis le début que nous nous
connaissons d'ailleurs mais il faut vous
gagnez madame la sénatrice ministre
monsieur le ministre abboud propos n'en
rajoutons pas en matière de polémiques
aller au bout de votre propos mais je
souhaite pouvoir le faire monsieur
président ça me paraît bien loin sans
être interrompus après mais rappelle
coquillages effet récemment monsieur le
président larcher a rappelé qu'il
n'était pas question de s'en prendre
personnellement aux uns et aux autres
et cet avertissement ne m'étaient pas
destinés donc je voudrais poursuivre
calmement mon propos voyez où je
m'exprime
c'était mon souhait merci monsieur merci
monsieur le président très calmement à
cet instant donc moi je dis je ne veux
pas être le garde des sceaux qui renvoi
aux assises un gamin de 18 ans et
quelques jours parce qu'il a eu une
relation avec une jeune femme pourquoi
l'écart d'âge on avait suggéré la
relation pérenne
moi j étais opposé pourquoi parce que
quand on s'est un peu comment
fonctionnent nos ados cinq jours pour
certains d'entre eux c'est une relation
pérenne
oui et une relation qui s'interrompt
puis qui reprend qu'est ce que l'on en
fait et comment le juge peut avoir les
critères suffisants pour inscrire au
fond dans une décision de justice
la pérennité d'une relation est
d'ailleurs bien en amont comment le
législateur pourrait-il inscrire ce
qu'est une relation pérenne sur touché
un gamin une gamine donc la pérennité
j'étais contre et je les dis en revanche
les carnages il est absolument
indispensable
il est indispensable pour quoi d'abord
pour des motifs de constitutionnalité
pardon
sinon on fait là encore un crime tout à
fait automatique et puis pardon moi je
le redis ensuite chacun on pense qu'il
en veut avec la conscience qui est la
sienne mais enfin mais enfin un jeune
homme de 18 ans et quelques jours qui a
entretenu une relation avec une
enfin de 14 ans et demi permettez moi
d'ailleurs de prendre des exemples moi
aussi pardon mais il est des relations
de cette nature qui ont perduré dans le
temps nous connaissons vous connaissez
peut-être des couples qui ont été formés
à cette époque qui sont encore
aujourd'hui de vrais couples stables et
qu'est ce que l'on dit à un moment aux
enfants de ces gens on leur dit le mari
donc le père de ses enfants a été un
criminel mais on marche sur la tête en
marche sur la tête
et ce qui me déplaît c'est le message
que vous en voyez vous dit que ce texte
est mauvais je sais pas si vous le vôtre
et moi à votre place un texte mauvais je
ne vote pas mais vous envoyer comme
message aux associations qui nous
regardent que tous les efforts que nous
avons faits au delà des clivages
politiques
que ce soit au parlement que ce soit à
la chancellerie
que ce soit ici naturellement en
commission des lois et devant
l'hémicycle tous ces efforts là au fond
ne servent à rien et cette loi est un
texte mauvais ça c'est un message
magnifique qui est envoyé aux gens qui
nous attendent et qui vous attendait
d'ailleurs quand vous étiez ministre
bien donc plusieurs demandes de j'ai
plusieurs demandes de prise de parole
madame billaut merci monsieur le
président donc comme vous le savez
effectivement moi j'avais proposé à un
seuil de 13 ans qui ne visaient aucune
exception bien entendu et je les dis
dans la discussion générale
je suis totalement opposé à supprimer
cet écart d'âge parce que nous devons
préserver les relations amoureuses qui
peuvent exister entre adolescents vous
avez fait référence un certain nombre
d'entre vous aux attaques dont j'ai pu
faire l'objet pendant juste après le
vote de ce texte
mais ce que je veux vous dire maintenant
c'est que j'ai aussi reçu énormément de
témoignages et le garde des sceaux vient
de l'évoquer de couples autour de moi
dont je ne connaissais pas l'histoire et
qui me disait eh bien voilà j'avais 14
ans il en avait 19 ans nos enfants ont
aujourd'hui 25 ans nous sommes toujours
ensemble
je te remercie c'est tuer tout à fait
dans dans le droit et c'est sévérité
le mans des choses dont il faut tenir
compte donc bien entendu moi je ne vais
pas ceux votés ces amendements de
suppression
alors évidemment lorsqu'on vend un
interdit à 13 ans on pose quelque chose
de clair lorsque vote un interdit à 15
il faut accepter qu'il y à des
exceptions parce que on ne peut pas
faire comme si ses relations amoureuses
n'existait pas elle existe donc bien
entendu je suivrai la rapporteure et le
garde des sceaux sur ces amendements
j'avoue que ce débat le débat lui-même
me pose problème
pas parce que nous débattons c'est ce
que nous avons l'habitude dans cet
hémicycle en tout cas au niveau du sénat
en respectant les points de vue de
chacun et de chacune
mais justement monsieur le garde des
sceaux dans mon propos dans mon
intervention général j'ai soulevé un
certain nombre de problèmes et de
difficultés à interpréter la loi et
c'est vrai que les la loi telle que là
nous nous apprêtons à la voter je les
dis elle est plus protectrice du point
de vue de mon groupe mais en même temps
elle est extrêmement complexe et tout le
monde ici n'est pas juriste nous sommes
parlementaire nous ne sommes pas tout et
toujours us et c'est heureux d'ailleurs
et moi j'ai besoin aussi dans le débat
de cheminées et d'avoir des arguments et
pas des polémiques
je pense que toutes et tous en tout cas
même si nous ne partageons pas les mêmes
valeurs
obligatoirement au niveau politique que
nous portons pas les mêmes projets je
vais dire on s'écoute et j'aimerais que
ça continue
manger un doute effectivement sur cet
écart d'âge je le dis et c'est pas parce
que je veux moins protégés etc
je pense que quelque part pardonnez moi
l'expression famille familière mais il
ya des trous dans la raquette
parce que je pense que ça peut être
moins protecteur par rapport notamment à
des jeunes de 14 ans parce que on a des
statistiques qui disent que les violeurs
de deux mineurs ont entre 18 et 24 ans
pour 65% alors j'entends bien monsieur
le garde des sceaux qui dit mais qui a
dit au début il faut faire un peu au cas
par cas faire en quelque sorte un peut
personnaliser les choses mais enfin on
connaît quand même le manque de moyens
de
justice ont comme l on connaît les
difficultés et je ne suis pas sûr que de
laisser les choses en interprétation des
juges et des magistrats soit si facile
que ça dans toutes les juridictions
donc il ya besoin d'un cadre dont j'ai
besoin d'arguments pour effectivement
être persuadé qu'en votant un peu quand
même dans la précipitation parce que il
ya déjà des lois qui ce qui se succèdent
mais moi j'aurais préféré qu'il y ait
une bonne fois pour toutes à un moment
donné le temps de la discussion sur une
loi qui soit loi globale et pas de
reprendre à chaque fois les choses
voilà peut-être que c'est comme ça et
j'entends aussi ans nous avons su nous
avons auditionné parce qu'au niveau du
parlement nous additionnons quelles que
soient nos groupes
eh bien j'ai entendu le syndicat de la
magistrature émettent des doutes sérieux
qui me font effectivement nous poser des
questions et j'aimerais avoir des
réponses et pas des affirmations sans
fondement madame de la gontrie
sur la notion de l'écart d'âge on a
suffisamment évoqué les uns ou les
autres
les conséquences que je serai là pouvait
avoir mais par rapport aux échanges qui
ont eu lieu je voudrais apporter
quelques précisions
quelques appréciations d'abord je le
disais tout à l'heure lorsque je disais
le code pénal n'est pas un distributeur
automatique
il ne faut pas considérer que parce que
une infraction est déterminé et qualifié
de criminel la personne va être
mécaniquement envoyé devant la cour
d'assises parce qu'il existe en droit
français le principe de l'opportunité
des poursuites
c'est à dire que le parquet après si les
circonstances de l'espèce
avant de décider ou non de renvoyer tel
ou tel devant la cour d'assises est donc
évidemment la situation qui est décrite
par la rapporteure ou par annick billon
rentrer dans ce type de catégorie
donc il ne faut pas être aveuglé par ce
par par ce risque car en fait il
n'existe pas la deuxième chose c'est que
heu
annick billon faisait état de 2
d'exception je ne sais pas d'ailleurs si
les couples qui se sont rencontrés aux
âges que vous évoquez avaient des
relations sexuelles par parenthèse mais
en tout état de cause on ne fait pas le
code pénal pour des exceptions on fait
des codes pénal pour des principes
généraux et ma conviction c'est que les
principes généraux doivent être claires
et s'appliquer de manière nette et que
dès lors que l'on rentre dans ce
raisonnement qui faisait que je le
disais dans mon intervention général 19
14 ans nous considérons que cela ne pose
pas de problème puisqu'il y aurait moins
de cinq ans d'écart balles dont 14 ans
et demi et 19
et bien moi je vous le dis je pense
qu'on a un problème on a un problème
une membre de 14 ans et demi et un jeune
adulte de 19 ans donc voilà pourquoi je
me permets d'insister je ne suis pas sûr
de vous convaincre mais j'essaye quand
même la dernière chose c'est que
je dirai au garde des sceaux moi vous
savez je suis dans cet hémicycle
j'échange des arguments et je ne pense
pas que les propos que je pourrais
qualifier mais je le pense même pas
totalement de d'injurieux soit très
utile à éclairer notre réflexion
pour ma part je m'en garderais bien
qu'il s'agisse de les adresser à un
collègue ou un membre du gouvernement
c'est à ce seul titre d'ailleurs que je
m'adresse dans ce cas au garde des
sceaux madame rossignol oui c'est une
explication de vote et bien entendu je
veux très cet amendement numéro 5 de
madame de la gontrie mais je voulais
revenir sur un argument qui a été
employée précédemment sur le fait que
celles et ceux qui défendent cet
amendement c'est à dire qu'ils pensent
qu'il faut poser l'interdît clair sans
et carnage n'aurait pas une bonne
compréhension de la jeunesse ou
voudraient se poser en censeur
voilà de nombreuses années que je lutte
par le plaidoyer par mon action
militante par ma fonction parlementaire
je les fais aussi quand j'étais ministre
je vous rassure monsieur le garde des
sceaux musée n'était pas garde des
sceaux de la chancellerie n'était pas
très aidantes
permettez moi de vous le dire contre les
violences sexuelles commises sur les
enfants j'ai lutté avant contre les
violences sexuelles contre commises
contre les femmes contre les agressions
sexuelles contre le harcèlement sexuel
contre la misogynie sexisme et à chaque
fois il arrive un moment où l'on nous
rétorque que nous nous posons en censeur
et vous avez exposé et reprises cette
expression
les censeurs sont toujours ceux qui
veulent protéger
c'est tellement mieux la liberté
sexuelle
c'est tellement mieux d'être empathique
à l'égard de ses amours d'adolescentes
entre quelqu'un de 14 ans et demi est
quelqu'un de 19 ans parce que au nom
toujours de la crainte de l'erreur
judiciaire de la butte droit qui
amènerait un auteur à une sanction qui
ne méritent pas on laisse les victimes
désemparés et je suis toujours frappé de
voir à quel point
l'erreur judiciaire est redoutée dans
cet hémicycle
quand il s'agit de celles qui pourraient
peser sur un auteur mais beaucoup moins
facile à appréhender et à combattre et à
nous mobiliser quand téhéran judiciaire
les ses victimes sans justice merci cher
collègue monsieur le ministre et ensuite
je vous propose s'il n'y a pas d'autres
demandes d'intervention de passer au
vote sur cet amendement sur le ministre
très brièvement madame la sénatrice vous
nous dites que la chancellerie à
l'époque vous étiez ministre n'était pas
aidantes mois il s'avère que je le suis
et dont sur ces questions et je pense
que tout le monde ici où presque tout le
monde vous non sans doute mais presque
tout le monde ici peut le dire
maintenant je voudrais même la sénatrice
et essayez de vous rassurer
quand la loi est prise bien sûr il ya
les décrets d'application pillaient des
circulaires d'application ou
naturellement les services de la
chancellerie qui savent écrire des zoos
procureur un certain nombre de choses
moi je ne crois pas on l'a suggéré tout
à l'heure madame la sénatrice de la
gontrie mais je ne veux pas dénaturer
ses propos évidemment qu'il y avait des
parcs et où on pouvait peut-être plus
facilement assimiler la loi que l'on
d'autres moi je n'ai pas du tout cette
certitude je pense que le juge et la
bouche de la loi et qu'il se fait
évidemment fort de l'appliquer au mieux
ça c'est la première chose que je veux
dire mais il faut aussi préciser les
exemples vous ont été donnés tout à
l'heure des lettres qui avaient été
reçus par madame la sénatrice
il ya des situations dans laquelle ce
sont les parents qui déposent une
plainte alors que les jeunes
adolescentes ou les jeunes adolescents
n'envisage pas du tout le dépôt d'une
plainte
est ce que vous savez parfois un un
retard à la maison au delà de l'heure
qui a été donnée ça peut générer des
explications un peu confuse et une
plainte
et moi je dis naturellement on doit
regarder les choses et qu'on doit faire
le distinguo entre une relation qui est
consentie et une relation qui ne le
serait pas et il faut ajouter c'est
impérieux de l'ajouter parce que sinon
on perd la raison si on n'a pas ça à
l'esprit si la relation entre la jeune
femme de 14 ans et demi le jeune homme
de 19 ans ou l'inversé d'ailleurs
si cette relation n'est pas une relation
consentie naturellement elle tombe sous
le coup de la loi pénale
ça n'est pas l'impunité cet écart d'âge
ce n'est pas l'impunité c'est l'impunité
dans le cadre pardonnez moi ça existe de
ce que l'on a appelé de ce que j'ai
appelé du ce que d'autres ont appelé des
amours adolescentes elles existent et je
ne veux pas être le censeur de cela au
nom et au nom de la protection des
victimes
c'est une protection sacré on ne peut
pas non plus s'asseoir sur tous les
principes qui sont une autre en matière
de charge de la preuve par exemple on ne
peut pas faire ça ça n'est pas possible
ça n'est pas l'essence même de notre
droit pénal
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est comme ça
et me semble-t-il on ne peut pas
transiger sur ces règles c'est aussi ce
que je tente de rappeler quand je dis
tout à l'heure l'émotion la passion
évidemment que ça suscite sans ce type
de débat forcément mais en même temps le
recul le droit la constitutionnalité
tout ça ça n'est pas rien non plus
surtout ici dans l'assemblée qui est qui
est la vôtre ont fait la loi et on l'a
fait avec un certain nombre de grands
principes qu'on ne peut pas oublier
voilà ce que ce que je voulais
madame la sénatrice je ne sais pas moi
non plus si je vous convie ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est aussi cela ça
n'est pas l'impunité c'était cardage
c'est la protection de deux jeunes
hommes de deux jeunes femmes qui pensait
mais parfois pour la vie parfois pour
quelques semaines mais qui ont ensemble
des relations et tout à l'heure en
réponse et puis je m'assois ensuite à
madame la sénatrice madame de la gontrie
vous avez dis je je crois à là encore je
ne veux surtout pas dénaturer vos propos
mais ces lettres que vous avez reçu ces
couples et ce qu'ils avaient des
relations sexuelles mais au planning
familial nous savons que des jeunes
femmes devant de la pilule à 14 ans et
demi c'est une réalité
on peut sur le plan moral ont discuté
pendant des heures le droit ne doit pas
se confondre avec la morale c'est une
réalité on le sait moi ces amours là je
souhaite les protège et voilà c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça et ça ne me paraît
pas hérétiques
bien nous en avons terminé avec le débat
sur cet amendement nous allons passer au
vote si vous le voulez bien
donc nous votons sur l'amendement numéro
5 qui est favorable à cet amendement qui
étaient contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté
nous passons la discussion de deux
amendements en discussion commune
le onze présenté par madame de la
gontrie ou amendement numéro 11
merci président le sujet a été abordé
tout à l'heure par notre collègue de
bell n'est qui évoquait d'ailleurs le
souhait qu'ils avaient pu être celui de
son groupe le sien en tout cas de
proposer un amendement qui est de
proposer une protection particulière aux
personnes en situation de particulière
vulnérabilité
c'est à dire maladie infirmité handicap
ou état de grossesse sachant que nous
sommes en train de prévoir une nouvelle
comment dire
termine à sion des seuils d'âge des
circonstances pendant lesquelles une
protection spécifique doit être accordée
il nous semble très important que ces
seuils d'âge s'applique différemment
lorsque les personnes sont en situation
de particulière vulnérabilité et c'est
pour cela que nous avons souhaité que le
seuil d'âge de 15 ans ne s'applique pas
dès lors que cette personne est
vulnérable et ça ne confirme pas que ça
ne concerne pas que les personnes en
situation de handicap mais aussi
infirmité maladie ou état de grossesse
c'est quelque chose d'important et tout
à l'heure notre collègue de bellelay
disait ce n'est peut-être pas possible
de le prévoir dans le code pénal si
c'est l'occasion aujourd'hui le monde
mon numéro 14
madame cohen oui c'est un amendement qui
effectivement se situe dans le dans le
même esprit où nous nous avons fixé un
seuil de non consentement pour les
jeunes porteurs de handicap et nous
l'avons fixé à 18 ans justement afin
d'instaurer un niveau de protection qui
soit à la hauteur de la vulnérabilité
des démineurs
je dois dire que j'ai suivi les débats
qui ont eu lieu à l'assemblée nationale
et je dirais plutôt que c'est un c'est
un amendement en tout cas pour ce qui
nous concerne d'appel parce que j'ai
tout à fait entendu ce qu'a dit le
secrétaire d'état monsieur taquet rien
taquet qui a expliqué que en fait il y
avait besoin de continuer à travailler
sur sept sur sept vulnérabilités d'aider
des jeunes qui sont en situation de
handicap
et voilà je voulais lancer le débat il a
déjà été lancé pour effectivement abondé
demandé à ce qu'il y ait une réflexion
beaucoup plus poussée sur la question et
que quelque chose soit fait je ne pense
pas et là c'est mon expérience dans tofu
nice qui parle je ne pense pas que nous
soyons en capacité en ce moment précis
de pouvoir le faire dans cette loi voilà
la rapporteure merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
c'est effectivement un sujet difficile
extrêmement lourd je vous remercie de
l'avoir abordée comme nous l'avions
abordé en première lecture puisque
c'était philippe millet qu'il avait
proposé des amendements qui était d
amendement d'appel
donc on ne peut pas ignorer ce sujet là
dans l'amendement numéro 11
en résumé le viol est constitué si la
victime mineure jusqu'à 18 ans souffre
d'une particulière vulnérabilité d'un
handicap d'un état de grossesse
donc je comprends bien attention
généreuse qu'anime les auteurs de cet
amendement
je pense que vous souhaitez surtout
protéger les mineurs handicapés bon il
ya tellement de sortes de 1,2 handicapés
cet apport du mandement il propose deux
qualifiés automatiquement de viols ou
d'agressions sexuelles les relations
call majeurs pourraient avoir les cas
mineurs jusqu'à 18 ans si le mineur est
particulièrement vulnérable tel qu'il
est rédigé cet amendement pose des
problèmes et il aurait manifestement des
conséquences qui serait excessive et
inappropriée avec un tel amendement âge
majeur qui aurait une des récents
sexuelles avec une jeune fille de 17 ans
donc qui serait enceinte dans votre
exemple serait automatiquement
l'auteur d'un viol la loi n'imposerait
pas de s'interroger sur le consentement
de la jeune fille ni même de se demander
si le jeune majeur a abusé d'une
quelconque autorité
concernant les jeunes handicapés on voit
bien que le seuil d'âge n'est pas du
tout pertinent pour ceux qui sont
atteints d'un handicap mental vraiment
enfin vous le comprenez bien quel que
soit l'âge l'âge physique n'a en rien à
voir avec l'âge mental
dans ce cas de figure ils peuvent être
tout aussi vulnérables à 30 ans 25 ans
u17 envoyons nos concernant le handicap
physique votre amendement y pose un
problème de principe dont on a déjà
entendu parler et qui vaut d'être
discutée doivent-ils être exclus de
cette majorité sexuelle reconnue à tous
les mineurs à partir de 15 ans est-ce
que ce handicap physique leur interdit
de consentir un rapport sexuel
j'ai vraiment je n'en suis pas convaincu
et c'est une question que je crois
vraiment peu opportune de trancher là
maintenant au détour d'un amendement
cette question est beaucoup trop
importante pour cela donc c'est une
demande de retrait sinon un avis
défavorable sur le ministre merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice assassi merci d'avoir rappelé
ce que vous avez entendu à l'assemblée
nationale adrien taquet qui devait être
ici à mes côtés au bond et qui est
retenu à l'assemblée qui vous pouvez
d'ailleurs de recevoir ses excuses a été
très très clair sur cette question et il
a rappelé ce que d'ailleurs madame la
rapporteure vient également de rappeler
qu'est ce que c'est que l'âge pour
certains handicapés mais je prend la
précaution de dire certains parce que
chaque situation est une situation
particulière parce que faire là encore
un crime automatique
c'est nier toute liberté sexuelle ou
handicapées au pluriel sans regarder ce
qui est le travail des magistrats les
situations particulières qui se
présentent à lui donc attention je pense
que c'est prématuré
il ya un travail qui est envisagée qui
est un travail très précis par adrien
taquet est ce que vous dites madame la
sénatrice mesfar me paraît frappé du
coin du bon sens amendement d'appel
parce que votre attention
notre humanité sont attirés par cette
question qu est une vraie question
évidemment à laquelle on peut pas rester
insensible mais on ne peut pas légiférer
à la hâte sur une question aussi
difficile que celle là je pars ailleurs
rappelé que déjà la loi pénale consacre
une circonstance aggravante dans
certaines hypothèses de vulnérabilité
notamment que le handicap et parfois la
loi dans certaines hypothèses
la loi facilite la preuve de la
contrainte
là encore quand il y à une vulnérabilité
inhérente un handicap
voilà ce que ce que je je je peux vous
répondre
évidemment je suis très sensible à la
façon dont vous avez exprimé les choses
les dix ans et tout en disant qu' il
était évidemment prématuré de légiférer
là dessus c'est un sujet vraiment
infiniment complexe et je suis
défavorable évidemment aux amendements
tels qu'ils ont été tel qu'il a été
présenté par madame de la gontrie bien
donc on a eu mal à mme de la gontrie
oui le garde des sceaux a parfaitement
bien fait de rappeler qu'il existe des
circonstances aggravantes
lorsque la victime est en situation de
handicap
vous noterez que cet amendement ne vise
pas que le handicap la situation
vulnérable peut être d'une autre nature
la maladie ou la grossesse mais il y un
paradoxe a accepté donc que dans notre
droit
il existe des circonstances aggravantes
lorsque la victime est en situation de
handicap et de considérer que la
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas le
prendre en considération c'est une
contradiction
donc si nous voulons être cohérent nous
devons prendre en compte cette situation
et enfin je répète qu' il y a quand même
curiosité à considérer lorsqu'on débat
au parlement que ce n'est jamais le
moment sur ce texte
ça nous a été régulièrement retournée
donc pourquoi est ce que ce ne serait
pas le moment aujourd'hui de légiférer
sur la protection des handicapés en
prétendant peut-être que c'est un
amendement vous savez en général on dit
dans ce cas là rédigés sur un coin de
table
c'est pas le cas donc c'est le moment on
peut le faire
rien ne s'y oppose dans le dans le nôtre
droit et ne ratons pas cette occasion
madame millions
merci monsieur le président d'abord
remercié les sénateurs qui ont déposé
ces amendements parce que la délégation
aux droits des femmes à travailler au
moment du projet de loi de lutte contre
les violences sexuelles et sexistes sur
7 sur ces violences faites aux femmes en
situation de handicap
nous avions mené de nombreuses auditions
et nous avions adopté à l'unanimité une
proposition de résolution pour lutter
contre ces vols violences faites aux
femmes en situation de handicap on le
sait les chiffres sont effroyables sur
les violences qui sont faites sur les
enfants en situation de handicap
par contre le sujet parle on en parle
beaucoup il ya eu cette proposition de
résolution il ya eu le projet de loi et
c'est vrai que je rejoins mes collègues
sur l'urgence qu'il y a à légiférer à
mieux protéger ses enfants
j'ai entendu les débats à l'assemblée
nationale j'ai entendu le ministre
adrien taquet et je pense que le sujet
n'est pas assez à ce stade pas assez
fourni pas assez étayé pour qu'on puisse
légiférer parce que pour moi il ya les
personnes en situation de handicap il ya
beaucoup de situations de handicap il ya
beaucoup de réponses à apporter des
réponses qui sont complexes et il ya
cette notion de vulnérabilité que je je
ne sais pas comment la définir à ce
stade des débats de manière précise
comment va-t-on déclaré une liste des
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
moi j'en suis incapable
donc oui c'est un sujet grave wind nous
devons nous en emparer très vite oui
nous avons trop attendu
merci pour ces amendements d'appel je
suivrai la rapporteure merci
oui merci monsieur le président je les
dis en tout cas pour ce qui concerne mon
groupe et moi même c'était un amendement
d'appel urgent c'est là effectivement je
crois que tout le monde le partage et
mais il ya besoin pour moi de plus il y
travailler parce que on ne peut pas
seulement régler cette question si je
puis dire au travers d'un d'un
amendement au coeur d'un article parce
que les handicaps sont multiples et si
on parle notamment des handicaps
cognitifs et bien le seuil d'âge que
nous proposions de 18 ans ne veut
absolument rien dire je partage qui a
été ce qui a été dit donc à la lumière
de ces éléments on engage le débat
j'ai entendu que que ce soit le garde
des sceaux où que ce soit le secrétaire
d'état
adrien taquet il ya cette volonté de
poursuivre le travail
donc nous allons rester vigilants mais
nous retirons notre amendement bien
madame de la gontrie le vôtre est
maintenu si j'ai bien compris bien donc
le 14 et retirer le 11 est maintenue
donc je vais soumettre aux voix
l'amendement numéro 11 qui et pour qui
et contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté nous poursuivrons avec
l'amendement numéro 6 présenté par
madame rossignol la proposition de loi
telle qu'elle est rédigé actuellement a
prévu un cadre des rois une dérogation à
ce fameux écart d'âge de 5 ans entre
l'auteur entre le majeur est la personne
mineure lorsqu'il s'agit de relations
obtenu en échange d'une rémunération
c'est à dire de prostitution pour faire
simple en france
la prostitution des mineurs et je
rappelle qu'un mineur c'est jusqu'à 18
ans est interdite et sanctionnée pour
autant nous sommes tous est jusqu'à
présent du moins jusqu'à aujourd'hui
communément et ensemble fortement
préoccupé de l'augmentation de la
prostitution des mineurs c'est
aujourd'hui un sujet de société qui
mobilise le secrétaire d'état chargé de
la protection de l'enfance mais aussi
tous les directeurs d'établissement à
caractère social les commissariats et
les gendarmeries et les juges pour
enfants
je propose donc avec mes collègues que
nous nous saisissions de ce texte qui
vise à protéger les mineurs des
violences sexuelles commises par des
majeurs pour étendre le crime de viol
sur mineure aux achats de services
sexuels par des mineurs c'est à dire que
je propose que les clients
des mineurs de moins de 18 ans soient
sanctionnés comme le sont les auteurs de
relations sexuelles sur des mineurs de
moins de 15 ans ça me paraît être
cohérent avec notre volonté commune de
lutter contre la prostitution des
mineurs mais pour lutter la contournant
la pression des mineurs il ne suffit pas
de lutter contre la pression des mineurs
il faut sanctionner des clients il n'y a
pas de prostitution sans client est un
client d'un mineur de moins de 18 ans
comme est à mes yeux un viol aggravé et
ce viol aggravé nous créons cette
planification ps passait pas ainsi qu'on
appelle mais avec notre incrimination
pénale nouvelle donc je propose au sénat
de prendre une décision forte peau de
protection des mineurs exposé à la
prostitution par les proxénètes et par
les clients
madame la rapporteuse alors là
effectivement pas ce que dit comme ça
sauf que sauf que moi j'ai toujours des
histoires et des histoires vraies dans
un collège du centre ville une un
collège donc de 6e à la 3e
voilà qu'une petite jeune fille et s'est
pas séparé sans ya quelques années
proposer des fellations tarifs et aux
copains
évidemment personne n'était au courant
donc elle se faisait son argent de poche
comme ça je vous rappelle que nous avons
mis les actes bucco-génitaux comme étant
des viols et nous avons raison nous
avons eu raison de faire ça d'où qu'elle
faisait tarifs et donc elle faisait
payer situation
la voilà arrivés gentiment au lycée
parce qu'elle ça l'empêchait pas de tête
une bonne élève et bien au lycée elle a
continué son petit business
sauf qu'au lycée il ya des majeures doc
avec cet amendement on en verrait le
jeune de 18 ans et un jour de la même
façon en prison donc même si quand on
écoute cet argumentaire et on a vraiment
l'impression que vous faites quelque
chose pour lutter contre la prostitution
et sage vous en féliciter c'est quelque
chose qu'on devra faire il faudra
travailler là dessus il ne faut pas
forcément considérée au thomas
typiquement comme un viol tous rapports
sexuels tarifés entre un majeur et un
mineur jusqu'à 18 ans il ya l'apparence
des choses et il ya les choses en vrai
dans la réalité
donc je comprends bien cette intention
de lutter contre la prostitution et je
pense que on en reparlera mais vous
noterez que ce texte vise à protéger des
mineurs de 15 ans en fixant des règles
de droit dérogatoire qui tiennent compte
de leur vulnérabilité et de leur manque
de discernement
l'adoption de votre amendement aboutir
et à traiter tous les mineurs de la même
manière sans distinguer la situation du
jeune de 17 ans et demi de celui qui en
a 12 c'est ça quand même c'est très
contestable
je note également que l' achat d'acte
sexuel auprès de mineurs et déjà
réprimer donc par le deuxième alinéa de
l'article 205 12 1 du code pénal issue
de la loi du 13 avril 2016 que vous
connaissez bien madame la ministre
visant à renforcer la lutte contre le
système prostitutionnel
et là à l'époque vous aviez mis une
peine de trois ans de prison qui était
prévu et l'article 1er bis eu de la
proposition de loi elle propose de
porter cette peine à cinq ans de prison
donc l'adoption votre amendement
pourrait donc un problème puisqu'il
créerait une double incrimination pour
les mêmes faits donc sur le fond il est
permis de s'interroger bien sûr sur les
raisons qui nous conduirait à passer de
trois ans de prison c'est la peine
adoptée par la majorité socialiste en
2016 à 20 ans de réclusion criminelle
aujourd'hui donc il convient de
conserver une proportionnalité dans les
peines que nous prévoyons et je doute
que celle-ci sera assurée avec cet
amendement
je les compléter en disant qu on note
que la peine encourue est une
contravention de cinquième classe punie
2500 euros en cas de recours à la
prostitution d'un majeur on passerait
donc d'une peine de 20 ans de prison
avec un mineur de 18 ans moins un jour à
une simple contravention avec un majeur
de 18 ans et un jour donc c'est vraiment
pas certain qu'un tel écart soit
véritablement proportionnée mais je
retiendrai vraiment de votre amendement
que nous devons lutter contre la
prostitution
en règle générale monsieur le ministre à
vis du gouvernement
oui monsieur le président le code pénal
c'est aussi une question d'équilibré
l'homme qui fait une jeune femme de 18
ans et un jour pour avoir des relations
sexuelles c'est 1500 euros damende est
le même qui a une relation sexuelle avec
une jeune femme de 18 ans moins un jour
s'il la paye ses 20 ans d'emprisonnement
et on vous a rappelé c'est assez cruel
d'ailleurs qu'il y a assez peu de temps
c'était à vos yeux punissable de trois
ans d'emprisonnement
dix sept ans d'inflation dite - ce n'est
pas rien mais vous voyez en matière
pellin c'est toujours la même chose
certains pensent que pour complaire les
victimes
il faut aller dans des seuils qui sont
qui ne sont jamais satisfaits au fond
c'est la surenchère dont je parlais tout
à l'heure en disant il faut faire
attention aux équilibres là parce que
sinon on est très très vite entraîner
les socialistes ont souvent dénoncé cela
d'ailleurs très souvent il avait raison
moi qu'on lutte contre la prostitution
oui bien sûr et d'ailleurs nous nous
nous créons une infraction
ça n'est pas rien tout de même et elle
est punie comme le viol quand il s'agit
de mineurs de 15 ans maintenant c'est
jamais assez ce toujours plus toujours
plus et toujours plus et toujours plus
disent attendre plus qu il y a quelques
jours quelques mois quelques années
peut-être
j'ai du mal à comprendre cette logique
et voyez vous on entre dans dans une
société qui qui qui d'un certain point
de vue ne connaît comme seule réponse
que la surenchère pénale qui a été
tellement souvent dénoncé par les
socialistes d'ailleurs bon je suis
totalement totalement défavorable à cet
amendement
madame de la gontrie
je suis très heureuse d'entendre le
garde des sceaux considérer que
l'inflation pénale n'est pas une réponse
satisfaisante et je pense que muni du
journal officiel car j'avais compris que
désormais dans les échanges
c'est ce document qu'il nous faut avoir
par devers nous nous aurons à y revenir
parce que certains textes qui vont venir
dans peu de temps d'ailleurs font
pourtant appel à 7
cette démarche mais dans ce texte
aujourd'hui il y à bien inflation pénale
concernant le mineur de 15 ans ou alors
je n'ai pas compris ce que nous sommes
en train de débattre
non ce n'est pas déjà pas mal
c'est à dire que ce que nous proposons
aujourd'hui c'est de protéger tous les
mineurs donc il ne s'agit pas de
renoncer à l'inflation pénal comme vous
le prétendez
il s'agit de savoir si cette inflation
pénale je ne la qualifie pas comme ça de
cette sanction juste pour les mineurs de
15 ans ne devrait pas s'appliquer à tous
les mineurs pour nous c'est oui madame
rossignol
il ne s'agit pas de faire de l'inflation
pénal vous savez l'inflation pénal c'est
une outil politique qui consiste à
parler au plus grand nombre pour faire
croire aux gens qu'on les rassure gens
tendent parfois un des ministres dans ma
vie j'ai tout entendu beaucoup de
ministres faire de l'inflation pénale et
puis je vois encore aujourd'hui ce genre
de comportement qui n'ont pas disparu
mais vous savez s'en prendre aux clients
des prostituées c'est pas très porteur
monsieur le ministre ce n'est pas une
inflation pénale qui vous rapporte
énormément de soutien
c'est au contraire s'attaquer à quelque
chose qui est souvent appelé le plus
vieux métier du monde à une banalité et
que moi je qualifie comme étant une
violence sexuelle exercée par les
clients sur les personnes prostituées
donc ne fait pas le coup de la démagogie
de la paix sont pénale parce que sur le
sujet ça tombe vraiment très très mal
en revanche je rappelle qu'un enfant
qu'un mineur de moins de 10 un mineur de
18 ans je précise mais qui se
prostituent est considérée comme
relevant de l'enfance en danger et de la
protection de l'enfance un mineur de 17
ans et 9 mois qui se prostituent est un
enfant en danger mais le client devrait
lui avoir une peine variable selon si le
mineur est un mineur de moins de 15 ans
ou un mineur de moins de 18 ans alors
qu'il est dans tous les cas un enfant en
danger
l'incohérence monsieur le garde des
sceaux elle n'est pas chez moi dans
cette affaire et des chez vous et en
plus je trouve toujours assez désarmant
que nous ayons ces discussions à partir
systématiquement de la protection de
l'auteur on ne parle pas des enfants
on ne parle pas des mineurs qui se
prostituent on parle de l'auteur qui
seraient contraints qui sera exposée
subitement à une plus grande synthe
champ pénal parce qu'il a eu une
relation sexuelle tarifée avec un mineur
d'une mineure de 18 ans au lieu de 15
ans
c'est le point de vue
thor c'est le point de de la faute
pénale et de la proportionnalité des
peines
du point de vue de l'auteur mais ce
n'est pas le point de vue que nous
devrions avoir sur la protection globale
des enfants de moins de 18 ans exposés
aux clients de la prostitution
je suis effectivement favorable à la
pénalisation des clients tous et c'est
la loi et je regrette qu'il n'y ait pas
plus de mobilisation dans les pouvoirs
publics pour faire appliquer cette loi
que les procureurs soient pas tous
mobilisés certains le sont d'autres le
sont moins et que les ministres chargés
d'appliquer ce droit soit pas non plus
mobilisée pour ça mais en revanche vous
promouvez de d'accord sur le fait que
protéger les mineurs de la prostitution
et des clients c'est une exigence
collective fondamentale bien nous en
avons donc terminée je crois avec les
explications vote sur cet article
sur cet amendement par nos amendements
numéro 6 donc nous allons passer au vote
qui est pour l'adoption qui contre qui
s'abstient n'est pas adopté un
amendement numéro 13 madame rossignol
commandement numéro 13 défendu avis la
commission
c'est le même sujet alors j'ajouterai
quelque chose dans la prostitution
puisque le sujet arrive ici
n'oublions pas ce qui arrive
actuellement qu'on appelle les sugar
baby les choux guerre des dix et avec
les sites qui s'appelle only fans tout
ça veut mais oui c'est catastrophique
tout ça donc on nous serons obligés on
pourra pas faire l'économie de discuter
de tout cela ensemble
ceci étant pour le moment sur cet
amendement numéro 13 qui concerne
l'agression sexuelle et qui est défendu
nous donnons là encore un avis
défavorable moment
défavorable défavorable bien donc nous
allons passer au vote sur l'amendement
numéro 13 qui est favorable à
l'amendement qui est défavorable qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
passons vol sur l'article 1er qui est
pour l'article 1er ainsi amendée qui et
contre qui s'abstient et est adopté je
mets ou voir l'article 1er bis b à qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté un amendement numéro 15
articles donc 1er bis b commandement
numéro 15 madame la rapporteuse c'est
une simplification rédactionnelle
modifications à l'actionnaire donc pas
d'explication gauthier pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté je
demandais s'il ya des explications de
vote à l'amour
explications de vote madame rossignol
merci monsieur le président je crois que
sur la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles commises par des majeurs sur
des mineurs plusieurs de mes collègues
et moi même et notre groupe ne nous
sommes pas abstenu au cours des
dernières années nous avons porté
obstinément les même sujets les mêmes
objectifs et nous avons cherché à les
faire partager
le plus largement au sénat et par les
ministres successifs
nous n'avons pas eu de succès immédiat
mais nous observons que le temps aidant
petit à petit par petits pas les choses
avancent je considère pour ma part que
sur ces sujets il faut pas faire les
choses à moitié et que le temps n'est
que l'aisne n'est pas l'ami des victimes
le temps n'est que l'allier
des auteurs et des auteurs impuni c'est
pourquoi avec mes collègues parce que
nous avons présenté des amendements
aujourd'hui qui ont été rejetées comme
l'avait été précédemment
tous nos amendements même si par la
suite ils ont été et sont revenus nous
avons décidé de nous abstenir sur ce
texte
nous avons voté à chaque fois
précédemment en serrant les dents et en
disant fin de compte
soyons du côté positif
voyons le verre à moitié plein et ne
nous obstinons pas ne nous arrêtons pas
sur ce qui vient à me dié la portée de
ce qui est voté aujourd'hui nous
considérons à cette étape que les
amendements que les amendements que nous
avons proposé et qui n'ont pas été
adoptée aurait considérablement amélioré
le texte et que les mesures qui visaient
réduisent trop fortement la portée du
texte pour que nous le votons donc le
groupe socialiste s'abstiendra et le
groupe socialiste poursuivra son travail
constant pour la lutte contre orléans
sexuelle et la protection des mineurs
bien je ne suis pas saisie de six balles
en bio explications de tous
merci monsieur le président madame la
rapporteure monsieur président de la
commission des lois monsieur le garde
des sceaux
je voudrais tout d'abord rameurs
remercier la rapporteure pour le travail
qui l a amené depuis le début du du
parcours de cette proposition de loi
un travail de co construction qui s'est
poursuivie ensuite avec l'assemblée
nationale et monsieur le garde des
sceaux
donc je souhaitais véritablement insisté
sur ce travail de co construction parce
qu'on le sait ces sujets ne sont pas des
sujets clivants politiquement nous avons
tous le même objectif la protection des
jeunes la protection des jeunes contre
les crimes sexuels nous avons avancé
aujourd'hui nous avons avancé nous avons
un solide âge c'était inimaginable
il y a deux ans nous avons réussi à le
mettre alors bien sûr certains ne sont
pas totalement satisfait mais ce seuil
d'âge il existe dans la loi nous avons
fixé un interdit
nous traitons de l'inceste l'inceste est
arrivé avec un tsunami en début d'année
le livre de camille kouchner a fait une
véritable déflagration médiatique on ne
pouvait pas ne pas s'en emparer donc
c'est une bonne chose qu'aujourd'hui des
dispositions claires et précises soit
inscrite dans la loi
las extorsion la prescription prolonger
sont autant d'avancé qu'on n'avait pas
imaginé
c'est vrai que je le disais lors de la
discussion générale tout à l'heure
lorsque le texte était inscrit à l'ordre
du jour à l'automne dernier nous
n'imaginions même pas réussir à mettre à
seuils d'âge à 13 ans dans la loi
aujourd'hui nous réussissons à mettre un
seuil d'âge à 15 ans donc
félicitons-nous de toutes ces avancées
donc ça marque un tournant véritablement
dans la manière d'appréhender les
violences sexuelles et les crimes
sexuels sur mineurs mais ça va pas être
suffisant là de nombreux sénateurs l'ont
dit sur ces bancs parce que comme le
disait notre collègue arnaud de belenet
tout à l'heure ia les violences faites
aux personnes et aux hommes et aux
femmes et aux enfants en situation de
handicap
mais la loi ne fera pas tout et bien
entendu il faut aussi de la prévention
de l'information et ça eh bien c'est le
travail qu'a annoncé le secrétaire
d'état adrien taquet et nous espérons
que ce travail va avancer très vite
parce que les victimes elles attendent
depuis trop longtemps et si nous autres
sommes autant à nous passionner cet
après midi dans des échanges parfois
passionnants et passionnés et bien c'est
parce que les victimes elles sont là à
la porte du sénat elles sont là dehors
et elles comptent sur nous pour mieux
les protéger
donc merci à tous pour ce travail et
merci à tous pour le travail de
construction fait avec le gouvernement
non madame madame cohen oui merci
monsieur le président effectivement
j'aurais préféré qu'on est peut-être un
débat un peu plus fournie sur le plan du
fond je trouve ça a manqué dans cette
dans cette étude de cette seconde
lecture sur cette proposition doit
protéger les mineurs des crimes et
délits sexuels et d'inceste je les dis
dans mon propos introductif
nous avons au niveau du groupe
communistes républicains et citoyens
écologistes et inquiétudes
ça a été redit mes collègues socialistes
ont porté un certain nombre
d'amendements qui à notre sens aurait pu
encore amélioré améliorer la loi
pardon la loi malheureusement ils n'ont
pas été retenus mais en même temps il y
à des avancées il ya des avancées qui
sont une étape une étape dans le combat
que nous menons à la fois en tant que
parlementaire ici mais pour celles et
ceux qui sont des militantes et des
militants des droits des femmes
c'est une étape importante un point
d'appui il faut continuer à être
vigilants
il faut continuer à se battre et
notamment jeudi d avancer parce que il
ya le seuil d'âge
il ya également de l'inceste et à la
prostitution des mineurs mais on voit
bien là qui a encore des résistances au
niveau de la prostitution et c'est pas
seulement la prostitution des mythes des
mineurs qui finalement offre si je puis
dire des résistances on a des problèmes
au niveau de la prostitution et de la
mise en application de la loi que nous
avons voté pour sanctionner
effectivement les clients donc il ya
tout ça encore à continuer à travailler
il ya un protégé au niveau des violences
sexuelles et sexistes
aussi les personnes et les mineurs
porteurs et porteuses de handicap
donc il ya des choses à continuer à
travailler nous allons être vigilants
par rapport aux engagements du
gouvernement sur ce qui a été dit ici et
à l'assemblée nationale mais dans l'état
actuel des choses parce qu'il y assez
avancé nous allons voter favorablement
cette cette loi en espérant que nous
allons ensemble aller plus loin parce
que effectivement il ya encore beaucoup
de choses beaucoup de choses à faire et
notamment pas seulement dans la loi
qu'il faut simplifier et aussi toutes
les tous les aspects préventifs éducatif
de moyens humains et financiers a donné
pour la formation des professionnels et
surtout ne pas laisser à la carte si je
puis dire les juridictions se
débrouiller tout seul il faut un cadre
et un cadre qui soit pas trop complexe
malheureusement c'est ce qu'on a fait
avec cette loi
j'ai une demande 2002 par le
rapporteur et du président de la
commission nous dans l'ordre vous vous
choisissez dans quel ordre
oui merci monsieur le président je
voudrais à mon tour remercié un
aiguillon pour le texte qu'elle avait
porté ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
la protection de l'enfance la sauvegarde
de l'enfance et la sphère de tous bien
sûr que vous allez continuer de
travailler autour de cette protection
mais nous aussi nous aussi on va
continuer parce que les évolutions
sociétales sont là que la prostitution
des mineurs nous fait bien évidemment
réfléchir qu'on doit travailler ensemble
dans un débat constructif sans un état
d'esprit forcément crispé on fait du
droit donc quelquefois on lit les choses
on n'a l'impression que ce qui est
proposé mais ça va être une bonne
solution
et quand on creuse un petit peu on
s'aperçoit que non il faut vraiment
écrire des choses qui soit sur le plan
constitutionnel parce que la
constitution c'est notre règle commune
qu'elles soient absolument
de ce côté-là il reprochable donc je
voudrais remercier chacun pour les
apports concernant ce texte parce que
nous avons fait des progrès même si ce
texte n'est pas l'idéal
même si ce texte ne préservera pas
encore tous les enfants d'un crime
nous avons travaillé ensemble à la
sauvegarde de l'enfance et je voudrais
vous en remercier
j'ai une demande de prise de parole de
madame benbassa vous peut-être on va
laisser parler puis monsieur le
président de la commission vous
conclurez d'une certaine manière ces
explications de votre madame benbassa
merci monsieur le président je me joins
à tout ce qui a été dit par madame cohen
et part et d'autres collègues c'est vrai
que ce texte est très important c'est
une étape
c'est triste connaît
besoin de la du livre de madame kouchner
pour que qu'on discute plus amplement de
l'inceste
c'est une avancée nous avons le devoir
de protéger les enfants et je crois que
ce texte s'il est appliqué correctement
va faire avancer la cause que nous
défendons tous et toutes
néanmoins c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu
introduire plus de d'amendements essayer
d'enrichir davantage ce texte je pense
que nous le ferons lorsqu on en parlera
encore une fois d'ici j'ai parce que
depuis quelques années nous avons
abondamment parlé est de des violences
sexuelles
alors je remercie
mes collègues madame billon je remercie
la rapporteure et et je voterai pour le
moment de mon groupe
c'était en espérant qu'on va l'améliorer
et dans l'avenir
merci je vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi je rappelle que
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe de l'union
centriste sur l'ensemble du texte il va
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos tant 346 exprimé 276
pour 276 contre 0 le texte a été adopté
[Musique]